I know you're not as quick as a vampire, but how quick are you at your multiple choice?
So do an either or.
Not quick.
Are you ready?
Christmas shopping, sorted or the last minute?
Last minute.
Christmas present, like the surprise or need to know?
Like the surprise.
Christmas Eve, family and friends...
...or friends outside, big night out?
Family and friends.
Okay.
I mean Christmas is...
Pecan or pumpkin pie?
Pecan.
Hollywood smile or British gnashes?
What's a gnash?
Gnashes are your teeth!
Oh!
We apparently have really bad teeth compared to Americans.
British gnash, people sometimes say that I have buckteeth,...
...I grew up with rabbit teeth.
So yeah, British gnashes.
High street or high fashion?
What's high street?
High street, you know, like rags.
Seriously, I like vintage rags.
Really, you like your vintage shopping?
Yeah, I'm much more comfortable in old clothes that had been worn by other people for many years.
So if I'm in a perfect date movie, "Twilight" or "Four Christmases"?
"Twilight"?
I think I would get in a lot of trouble if I said the other.